bonsoir mercredi 6 mai 2015 il est
l'heure du journal de la rédaction comme
chaque soir du lundi au vendredi voici
les principaux titres de l'actualité
locale
le club de tennis de table est telle en
cours qui vient d'annoncer la fin de son
aventure en pro a si les résultats sont
bien là le manque de moyens explique les
choix des dirigeants sponsors
collectivités locales n'apportent pas
assez de garanties pour l'avenir
les rêves en couleur c'est le thème de
la journée mondiale du coloriage qui se
déroule aujourd'hui un fabricant de
produits d'écriture et de peinture en
est à l'origine afin de récolter des
dons pour l'association sos villages
d'enfants
et puis à voisins le bretonneux les
salariés d'europcar qui sont toujours
mobilisés ils ont saisi le tribunal pour
faire annuler le projet
d'externalisation de la direction les
salariés du service informatique et
d'europcar internationales ont donc
repris le travail malgré cette
mobilisation reprise du travail le 22
avril dernier après un mois de grève
pour protester contre l'externalisation
de leur service à compter du 1er juin
une externalisation qui toucherait elle
50 personnes la décision est maintenant
entre les mains de la justice
hier 24 membres du service étaient
présents au tribunal des prud'hommes de
rambouillet avec pour objectif de faire
annuler tout simplement ce projet on les
soupçonne de vouloir faire cette
externalisation au lieu de faire ce
qu'ils appellent un pse nous ce qui nous
allait pas c'était que l'on nous fasse
quitter europe car ils ne voulaient ils
ne veulent plus de nous alors d'accord
on ne perd pas notre emploi ils disent
eux mêmes ils répondent que l'on garde
nos salaires en gare des choses on garde
notre contrat mais ce n'est pas une
raison d'abord on n'est pas assuré de
notre avenir dans les sociétés dans les
sociétés de services et ensuite on n'a
rien demandé on n'a pas demandé ça hier
matin nous étions prud'hommes au conseil
des prud'hommes de rambouillet notre
avocat défendu
l'idée que cette externalisation n'était
n'était pas légale que les conditions
n'étaient pas réunies pour qu'elle
puisse se faire on attend la décision de
26 mais on reste vigilant sur tout ce
qui se passe qu'est ce qui comment ça va
se passer à capgemini quelles seront nos
statuts ensuite tout ça de près on reste
on reste sur le pied de guerre j'ai
envie de dire c'est officiel le club de
tennis de table des longs cours qui a
décidé d'arrêter sa section élite dames
pour raison économique à la fin de la
saison les élans courtoise qui ont donc
disputé hier soir mardi leur tout
dernier match en proie au plus haut
niveau face aux championnes en titre
championne de france metz le reportage
est signée mickey l'ennemi d'euros et
william l c'est un petit séisme dans le
monde du tennis de table en france la
section féminine élite d'elancourt ne
sera plus en pro à l'année prochaine
pour des raisons économiques et
dirigeants viennent d'annoncer cette
décision malgré la très belle cinquième
place de l'équipe dans ce championnat de
france la structure ne peut plus
supporter les frais de fonctionnement de
la section
déplacement important avec beaucoup de
journées c'est des conditions d'accueil
c'est également des joueuses rémunérés
et pour une structure amateur telle que
la nôtre
les sponsors n'étant pas forcément au
rendez vous toutes les collectivités
nous aidant pas hauteur espérée
on est obligé de faire un choix et
d'arrêter c'est une décision de notre
part d'arrêter la peau selon les dix
régions les subventions versées par les
collectivités territoriales ne sont pas
à la hauteur d'un club de pro à
la pilule a du mal à passer quand même
pas on est quand même on est quand même
l'équipe dans le département des
yvelines qui évolue hormis le psg parce
que je ne compte pas le paris saint
germain mais on est un club qui vous au
plus haut niveau national en france on
va faire cinquième 2,3 cette année ce
qui est une excellente saison et on
obtient arrive à avoir aucune aide sur
cette équipe là une décision qui a un
impact direct sur les joueuses élan
courtoise les membres de cette équipe
doivent s'expatrier aux quatre coins de
l'hexagone pour continuer à pratiquer
leur sport au plus haut niveau
je vais demander mais il y en a
plusieurs qui veulent pas parce que
c'est déjà ils ont déjà recruté j'ai
demandé à schiltigheim en alsace on
attend parce qu'on sait pas s'ils vont
monter en pro b
ça va être la pro b mois souvent ça va
pas être la proie donc
voir derniers matches en pro a pour elle
en cour le 26 mai prochain contre saint
quentin dans l'aide
le club or les cendres et ensuite l'eau
nationale dès la saison prochaine
aujourd'hui mercredi pose de la première
pierre de l'entrée du nouveau quartier
de villas roi à guyancourt le chantier
en face du technocentre a débuté en
janvier il se déroule sur un périmètre
de l vingt mille mètres carrés entre la
rue philippe delorme et l'avenue léon
blum le projet a coûté près de 40
millions d'euros majorité des
investissements privés il comprend un
hôtel 83 logements privés une maison de
santé pluridisciplinaire encore à des
commerces et un parking première étape
des travaux et qui doit s'achever en
2016 la seconde en 2017 avec
l'intégration d'autres commerces ainsi
que des logements et des nouveaux
bureaux
un projet d'envergure qui a reçu le prix
de la pyramide d'argent c'est une
récompense pour les meilleurs programmes
immobiliers régionaux répondant à des
critères de performance thermique et
d'intégration environnementale de
durabilité et d'esthétique et
d'innovation écouter hubert godet c'est
l'architecte de ce projet au micro de
florane parfait l'entrée du quartier de
villas roi se décompose sur deux
terrains donc celui ci qui est la
première tranche et ensuite celui qui
quitta à droite lorsque l'on rentre dans
le
guyancourt et donc l'idée était
architecturalement d'avoir une façade
qui était très proche dans son esprit
entre la partie gauche là qu'est la
première tranche dans lequel vous verrez
donc l'hôtel et ensuite à droite
les bureaux qui auront une architecture
qui sera qui sera assez similaire mais
les rêves en couleur c'est le thème de
la journée mondiale du coloriage qui a
lieu aujourd'hui
comme chaque année le 6 mai créé à
l'initiative de la fondation stadler
fabricants de produits et d'écriture et
de peinture cette manifestation
rassemble plus d'un million d'enfants à
travers une trentaine de pays bonsoir
régulière vous êtes le directeur
marketing de la fondation dont c'était
de leur bon on va tout de suite précisé
que cette journée du coloriage qui est
très ludique c'est aussi pour la bonne
cause
et puisque l'objectif est de récolter
des fonds pour sos villages d'enfants
absolument c'est exactement pour ça
qu'on fait de décider des enfants
aujourd'hui comme vous l'avez dit c'est
une manifestation qui se passe au niveau
mondial puisque toutes les filiales du
groupe gt de l'air sont sollicités ainsi
que les agents commerciaux de manière à
faire dessiner des enfants soient dans
des mairies soit dans des bibliothèques
soit dans des centres de loisirs est
évidemment à l'école puisque c'est là
qu'on trouve le plus enfants et parce
que ça se déroule donc aujourd'hui le 6
mai mais ça peut se prolonger dans
certaines communes ce sera un petit peu
plus tard je pense à saint cyr l'école
c'était prévu pour aujourd'hui ça a été
décalée pour des raisons d'agenda ce
sera au mois de juin concrètement
comment ça se passe
dessiné pour récolter des fonds alors
décidé pour l'heure il suffit d'avoir
des adultes qui sont concernés et qui
décident d'organiser une journée du
coloriage avec des enfants encore une
fois se prêter à l'école ou ailleurs ils
soumettent leurs projets à la fondation
et la fondation va décider si oui ou non
on peut les intégrer et à ce moment là
nous envoyons un colis dans lequel il y
à du matériel de coloriage du matériel
de dessin il y a des feuilles il y a des
petits cadeaux pour les enfants qui vont
participer une fois que le dessin
réalisé on invite les enfants à offrir
ce dessin à leurs proches et on demande
aux proches de faire un petit don pour
sos villages d'enfants
c'est le but donc au niveau mondial de
récolter de l'argent pour cette
organisation qui est une des plus
connues au niveau mondial c'est une
association pardon qui a pour but de
placer des enfants
de manière à ce que les fratries ne
soient pas séparés quand les parents ne
sont plus là pour aider des enfants fait
avec leurs enfants ont fait en sorte
avec sos villages d'enfants que les
fratries ne soit pas séparé et pour ça
elle choisit la jeune enfant construit
des villages recrute des personnes
qu'ils appellent des mères sos et dont
le but est d'aider les enfants et de les
éduquer comme si c'étaient leurs propres
enfants il vit 24 heures sur 24 avec eux
il les emmène à l'école ils font les
devoirs ils font des activités de
loisirs se sont si une nouvelle famille
qui est recréée pour la pour la fratrie
à l'opération a été lancée il ya
maintenant sept ans vous allez récolter
combien depuis l'heure actuelle en
france on en est à huit mille ha pardon
70000 euros
là on espère casser la baraque
pour cette huitième édition et ça
permettait le type de réalisations
concrètes
alors justement les villages dont on
parlait dont je vous parlais ce sont des
villages qui évidemment ont besoin
d'être agrandie de tomber lee d'être
aménagé d'être rénovée et on n'a pas si
vous voulez un programme spécifique
réservé à la fondation jeter de l'air
mais c est choisir votre enfant qui
dépense cet argent comme suivant ses
besoins
donc c'est aujourd'hui cette journée
mondiale du coloriage qui était lancée
par votre votre fondation ça va se
dérouler même jusqu'au 4 juillet où on
le disait et c'est un grand concours il
ya une attaque en règle adressant qui va
s'afficher
comment ça va se passer pour la partie
concours alors tous les enfants qui ont
décidé qu'ils ont envie de participer au
concours on voit ce dessin chez jeter de
l'air et on va réunir un jury qui va
choisir les dessins en fonction de mes
deux des tranches d'âge il y a trois
tranches d'âge et en fonction de ça
c'est pas vraiment parce que le dessin
est le plus beau mais c'est peut-être le
dessin qui va être le plus porteur
d'émotions qui va nous qui va nous faire
plaisir et quand qu'on va qu'on va
récompenser jordan cette adresse postale
pour envoyer c'est un journée mondiale
du coloriage 64 rue ernest renan à
nanterre 92000 nanterre adresse qui
devrait s'afficher dans un instant je
vous pardonne à 10,6 et voilà d'ici à la
fin de cette cet entretien le thème de
cette année on n'a pas parlé c'est le
rêve en couleurs rêve en couleurs
absolument le perv qu'il faut
il faut toujours avoir une part de rêve
et ça c'est pour les petits comme pour
les grands même nous nous avons besoin
encore de belles part de rêve et donc on
demande aux enfants d'imaginer leurs
rêves ou d'or retranscrire les rêves
qu'ils ont eue du moment où ils seront
cool c'est une opération qui mondiale
c'est à dire que le coloriage fonctionne
très bien quel que soit le pays
c'est une des activités qui est vraiment
un bon papa dire internationale mais qui
est universel des pays où s'amarrent
sommeil dando eh bien on vous allez
peut-être surpris mais c'est en france
qu'on a les meilleurs résultats au
niveau européen nous sommes devant même
notre société mère qui est allemande
nous sommes même devant les allemands au
niveau de la collecte de l'eau si vous
posez cette question c'est parce que la
société est un travail sur tous ces
petits outils qui permettent de faire du
coloriage chicha du monde et dessiner et
écrire
et ça marche plutôt bien malgré la
concurrence des tablettes par exemple ça
reste dans l'éducation des enfants il
reste évidemment une part très
importante dont le pour le développement
de l'anneau tracy de la motricité qui
est l'écriture qui est le dessin qui est
le travail manuel aussi pour oublier les
les pâtes à modeler les choses comme ça
mais le dessin est extrêmement important
parce que ça permet d'exprimer pour
l'enfant ce qu'il ressent à un moment
donné on sait très bien que
malheureusement pas parler d'autres
choses pas très gai mais après un
traumatisme ont fait dessiner des
enfants pour savoir ce qu'ils ont
vraiment au fond d'eux-mêmes et voilà
alors ça c'est le mauvais côté mais
aussi le côté bon on est content de
dessiner ne serais-je proféra dessin
pour ses parents pour il a pour d'autres
enfants quels sont les bienfaits du
coloriage c'est la question qu'ont ça
nous allez vous poser aujourd'hui dans
les rues de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est notre question du jour métro
trottoir allez art-thérapie là qui font
aujourd'hui c'est super effectivement ça
permet à l'enfant de se concentrer d'une
part et puis je pense que ça l'est
permet d'avoir une certaine motricité
fine et c'est ça peut rendre de gay ça
peut éveiller d'enfants si ça peut ça
peut aider dans la jeunesse maya franco
l'oreiller a pas dépassé aussi ça nous
aide à écrire c'est pour tenir bien
stylo apprendre à écrire en attaché et
aux 6 puis cher couleurs pour connaître
ses couleurs ça peut apporter
je suis pas une certaine détente ça nous
permet aussi de cesser de s'échapper
aussi de peut-être de des soucis
quotidiens
une petite page de coloriage ça fait du
bien c'est très sérieux coloriage même
les adultes aussi m alors moi
malheureusement non aujourd'hui
absolument achète pour ne pas la nommer
qui a développé une collection qui
s'appelle l'art thérapie et qui a pour
but de faire que laurier les adultes
pour qu'il se détende
c'est un anti stress et plein de motifs
il ya des dizaines et des dizaines de
bouquins qui ont été éditées et veut
dire que donc on en profite évidemment
parce que c'est bien beau d'avoir un
cahier à colorier mais faut avoir des
outils tapas la city juste pour vient
souligner que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
vous avez loupé aussi des nouveaux
outils estime éric crime numérique des
salles or on a parenthèse pour les pour
les très grands on a effectivement un
stylo numérique qui permet d'écrire et
de sur une feuille de papier et de
retranscrire ce que l'on a écrit sur
l'ordinateur mais ça c'est les avait
vraiment pour les grands pour ce qui est
d'un usage on va dire plus familial on a
maintenant des stylos des crayons pardon
des crayons graphites qui d'un côté
écrivent parce que c'est un crayon
graphite et de l'autre côté conte un
petit embout qui permet de d2 puis y est
de dessiner de taper sur une tablette
numérique sur un écran tactile quels
qu'ils soient d'ailleurs le coloriage
n'est pas mort vous l'avez compris c'est
aujourd'hui la journée mondiale du
coloriage dont nous parlons avec vous la
fondation cette aide leur peut-être un
mot aussi pour conclure sur cette
fondation et sur son objectif sur le but
alors en fait jeter de l'air c'est une
société qui n'est pas capitalistique
dans le sens on a longtemps on n'est pas
coté en bourse on n'a pas d'actionnaires
nous sommes une fondation c'est quelque
chose que l'on retrouve un peu
en allemagne on a également d'autres
exemples comme le lego qui doit être la
loire je crois et donc ses fondations
sont reconnues d'utilité publique en
échange de quoi elles doivent investir
une partie de leurs bénéfices dans l'est
dans l'éducation et nous on soutient des
thèses de doctorat dans certaines
universités prestigieuses comme celles
de munich puisque c'est pas très loin de
notre me notre maison mère où l'usiné où
le where langen et puis il ya cette
opération de coloriage journée mondiale
du coloriage vous pouvez y participer
encore et ce sera pour la bonne cause
puisque ce sera pour sos villages
d'enfants
merci et müller des traumas c'est sur ce
plateau culture à présent jean-françois
oudry expose ses paysages jusqu'au 5
juillet à la commanderie des templiers
s'était elle encourt l'artiste peintre
qui ne se consacre pas qu'aux paysages
malgré tout une oeuvre surprenante que
nous détaille oriane prénom
jean-françois oudry ne travaille pas sur
ce qu'il voit dans le réel ou à travers
des photographies
il invente ses paysages pour mieux
comprendre son travail
oriane prévost médiatrice culturelle
nous a servi de guide qu'ils
représentent des paysages qui sont
inventés mais dans chacun de ses
paysages et bien on peut trouver la
trace de l'activité humaine
alors on va jamais trouvé d'êtres
humains l'être humain n'est pas
représentée mais à chaque fois vous avez
vraiment là tu râles ses stigmates de
l'activité humaine vous allez avoir des
trous des routes des creuses allait
avoir des talus on voit qu'il ya eu
quelque chose peut-être un paysage post
industrielle ou alors paysages agricoles
ou d'android et carrière peut-être enfin
en fait on voit vraiment ces traces de
l'activité humaine
une volonté de sa part de travailler sur
le noir et blanc ont véritablement il a
voulu faire cet exercice mettre en avant
le noir et blanc s'exercer à ce travail
peut-être aussi on peut faire une
comparaison avec la photographie
on s'aperçoit en regardant bien les
oeuvres que finalement il de la couleur
il ya des taches de couleurs qui
ressortent et en s'approchant on voit
véritablement qu'il n'y a pas du tout
que du noir et blanc il ya du bleu du
violet du orange du verre mais
effectivement c'est ce groupe ad
forcément des couleurs très vives et
c'est un petit peu dissous dans le
tableau
m
on se rend compte en fonction du point
donc on regarde le tableau d'où on
regarde le tableau que certaines choses
a semblé très structuré très précise et
quand on s'en approche
et bien finalement tout est flou donc
une tâche qui de loin peut faire penser
à un arbre dès qu'on s'approche un petit
peu mais même sans être à 10 cm en étant
à 50 voire 1 mètre
et bien finalement ça devient qu'une
tache parmi d'autres
une notion de figuratif et abstrait dans
le travail plastique ou jean françois
gaudry veut montrer le paysage tel qu'il
imagine avec une note toujours de poésie
à découvrir jusqu'au 5 juillet
et pour un point complet sur l'actualité
culturelle sur notre secteur rendez vous
ce mercredi soir juste après le journal
pour kiosque avec catherine sultan
le week end s'est tenue la journée des
terroirs et des métiers d'art à
rambouillet à l'occasion de découvrir
des artisans d'art qui présentent leur
savoir faire
alix velits a débuté dans l'hôtellerie
de luxe puis elle a fondé avec son
associé une société de création
elle confectionne aujourd'hui bijoux et
accessoires sur demande
vous avez des passants qui sont en acier
et en cristal de roche c'est à dire du
strass et alors c'est précis pour ce
soir mais on élit m il doit y avoir une
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 à peu près 15
15 actions pour faire le bracelet pour
ce qui lui comme ingrédient c'est dur au
diable c'est à dire ça ne bouge pas ça
ne change pas de couleur de robe bien
une petite housse de platine et ça c'est
en acier le reste comme je me disais
c'est en cristal de roche
les voilà le bracelet
qui se ferme qui possèdent des deux
côtés un bracelet réalisé en 15 minutes
c'est à la fois rapide et personnalisé
alix fait partie des cinquante exposants
présents parmi eux une autre artisan
d'art fleurs assistante-réalisatrice
pendant trente ans elle a changé de
métier il ya sept ans et a fait de sa
passion une profession je dessine
d'abord le motif sur une seule papier a4
voilà et après je le grade 6 à peu je
fais des as et si ça peut correspondre à
l'objet lui-même parce que ça chaque
objet demande une folle ou du talent
donc je dessine à main levée sa venue
c'est une pâte
je suis à peu près à deux centimètres de
l'objet je te lis comme un crayon je
laisse tomber les pattes et je dessine
le contenu que vous voyez ici
après quand ils assèchent jeudi au four
après je mets le peintre retry une
manifestation proposée par le lions club
de rambouillet qui permettait de
collecter des fonds pour financer des
actions caritatives de l'association
directement du producteur au
consommateur c'est l'opération lancée
par le parti communiste ce jeudi soir en
partenariat avec le mouvement des
exploitants familiaux le pcf qui veut
ainsi prouver que l'on peut acheter des
produits de qualité convenable c'est la
troisième année que cette opération se
met en place un producteur pourra par
exemple proposer de la viande charolaise
à 14 euros le kilo cette vente va se
dérouler ce jeudi 17h30 et devant
l'ancienne mairie de trappes également à
saint-cyr-l'ecole devant l'école jean
macé cette fois ci à 19 heures on écoute
jean yves maximilien c'est le secrétaire
de la section du parti communiste
français sur saint cyr l'école justement
c'est de la viande qui est donc produite
dans l'allier qui est transformée dans
l'allier et
le producteur lui suit sa viande c'est
bien sa viande qui va être dans nos
assiettes bientôt ce qui se passe c'est
que la grande surface le la grande
coopérative qui achètent en fin de
compte souvent elle tend à baisser le
prix d'achat au producteur et du fait en
effet des différentes marges des
intermédiaires
elle arrive dans la grande surface à un
prix nettement plus élevé parce que tout
le monde s'est servi un petit peu quoi
donc nous ce que l'on justement on est
en cause ce système est donc on prouve
que c'est possible de faire autrement
avec cette mise en relation directe du
producteur au consommateur et les
personnes intéressées peuvent réserver à
l'adresse mail qui s afficher l'image
affichée voilà qui est à l'écran à
présent c'est la fin du journal de ce
mercredi 6 mai je vous retrouve demain
aux mêmes horaires pour une nouvelle
édition très bonne soirée